i thought this was a bone i think it is
yeah it's like
it looks like a potato it's like a
kneecap yeah i think it's a kneecap oh i
wish it wouldn't have
and soup is actually super delicious but
before we get back to the video just
want to say a huge thank you to
squarespace for sponsoring today's video
we're gonna be talking about them at the
end so make sure to stick around
what's up guys today and christina are
coming over with their kids
and we're gonna have a barbecue dinner
and uh
watch some nba finals tonight so
tonight's potluck and aunt
decided out of all things that he could
be bringing over he wanted to bring
chinese soup now for potlucks we don't
usually get chinese soups as something
that someone brings but growing up with
chinese soups that my mom made
i know chinese soups are very rich in
nutrients a lot of veggies in it
so why not and because ant wanted to
bring some chinese soup i decided that i
was gonna make chinese style
barbecue so growing up my mom used to
make this ginger and garlic chicken that
she would always barbecue every sunday
and it's super nostalgic and i haven't
made that in a long time i spend a lot
of my cooking energy just
researching and learning about new
things i hardly ever go
back and remake things that i've already
known or
are nostalgic to me and on top of that
i'm also going to make some
chatsu i recently came out with the
classic video a couple months ago gonna
recreate that for today
[Music]
uh
[Music]
all right time to fire up the grille
today we're going to be smoking with
some applewood applewood
[Music]
uh
who do we have here i don't know i'm not
even recording here yet you're not
i almost did you started before me i
broke your focus yeah
i was telling my vlog that because of
your soup it inspired me to do
more of an asian style flavored marinade
for my chicken
and then i made uh toss you
all because of your soup so you led the
way with the menu asian beans trying to
make something really easy
you can get beer on me getting b-roll
yeah
[Music]
that looks like mom's soup right there
did your dad teach you to cook or did
your mom teach you to cook
like chinese stuff my mom your mom yeah
i just actually started recently asking
about it really
before like i learned everything else
you know like french cuisine yeah
because that was more exciting because
it's like not
from what you grew up with so it's like
more exotic right now that um
me and christina have been living
together for such a long time without
parents yeah i miss the freestyle
cooking so i'm trying to start
asking my mom damn the same way too like
living with tiff like
like she's more accustomed to mexican
food so i could try to learn how to make
mexican fruit but i get like
kind of homesick and i want chinese food
and
well i don't know it's kind of like hard
to like complain it's like we used to
live in the 66
like in like monterey park yeah which is
like where all the chinese food is
at but i was too lazy to go out and get
it but buying food and suv is not the
same as
a home cooking place exactly yeah
restaurant restaurant food is different
from
home food it's about comfort food yes
exactly and
i over the years i've asked my mom for a
lot of different recipes that chicken
right there is my mom's recipe oh nice
so yeah
so famous mama chan recipe mama chan
recipe and then the thing about asking
your parents for recipes is that
they don't actually give you
measurements like a little bit of this a
little bit of that a little bit and i'm
like
all right i guess i'll uh i'll figure it
out on my own
[Laughter]
[Music]
put all the goodies in there little
chicken feet coming out
[Music]
nature's straw
soup is served chicken is there
potassium is cut up ready to go with
some rice
yeah that is like signature like chinese
family you can't grow up chinese and not
have had that in your house
if you didn't then
i thought this was a bone i think it is
yeah it's like
it looks like a potato it's like a
kneecap yeah i think it's a kneecap oh i
wish you wouldn't have seen
that i mean it's a it's a bone it's just
a bone
it's an herb it's an herb it's an herb
from an animal part
you guys are making it worse there's
more in there
no no they're trapped they're not
they're all potatoes potatoes
i'll put it in there i was gonna put it
in the mouth
i'll take this one you should've told me
it was a potato
it's a potato but you but it's a potato
you don't want to bite into
it's too late i'm already grossed out i
just
i would be fine if i just didn't know
where it came from that would be
perfectly fine
like that's why i can't do the chicken
feet because they look like chicken feet
true yeah they look like this and
they're staring at you inside the soup
all right so today we got to invite aka
and ray
and introduce them to leia and enzo and
they get to have a little play date at
her house
and like tiff said in one of her ig
stories we bought a whole bunch of kid
toys
so we're the uncle and aunt with the
with the cool toys at the house with no
actual child here
[Laughter]
hey enzo what's up what's that
what's is that your favorite toy what is
that is that a snake that's pretty good
you're on you're getting closer
oh no
[Music]
it doesn't match i know we have to make
a match huh anza you want to help
you want to help no no you're like
i just let her struggle yeah i'm walking
away yep i'm gonna stay right here
i have my snake in my football yep i'm
coming back i'm gonna help i'm gonna
help
no you know what i think you're smarter
than me because i wouldn't have gotten
that far
i would have struggled too
yeah that's what i usually do with
rubik's cubes i just put them down and
say
not for me we got going on over here the
tiniest cutest little slice of cheese oh
that is really tiny and cute
that's that the best cheesecake you'll
ever have in your life
so michael went to a place called uncle
tatsu famous for oh they even have a
logo on the
on the on the cheesecake itself is the
ube flavor
[Music]
[Laughter]
dang it
[Laughter]
do it again do it again
action
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
here i'll eat that one you guys take
this one you guys take this one
it's purple gold
[Music]
this guy right here is so spongy
and so soft it's like air it's like if a
sponge
instead of absorbing water absorb air
it's so good
[Music]
go for it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
eating all the food because maya is
scared of all these people
listen
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
once again thank you squarespace for
sponsoring today's video with
squarespace squarespace is a powerful
and easy to use platform for you to
create your website with squarespace you
can connect with your audience
send email communication leverage
audience insights and most importantly
generate revenue now if you want to blog
squarespace has powerful blogging tools
to help you build your community it can
display all your social media posts in
one place
so your followers can easily find them
and share them what if you want to start
your own store
squarespace has powerful ecommerce
extensions there's also a new
third-party tools to help you manage
your inventory
promote products streamline your
bookkeeping and ship items across the
globe
so go to squarespace.com for a free
trial go to squarespace.comcase to save
10 of your first purchase of the domain
or website
check them out peace
[Music]
you